depuis que j'étais
enfant, il y a certains personnages, certaines
choses que vous avez vues et qui ont un
impact sur vous et qui restent avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous et Godzilla étiez l'un d'entre
eux [Musique] c'est un honneur d'être
invité par notre  amis et collaborateurs
aussi et légendaires pour jouer dans ce
monstre, il
y a un héritage qui remonte à 70
ans que nous voulons respecter
donc nous devons tout honorer et
maintenir la cohérence et ce qui
était excitant était de le dire à un humain  histoire à l'échelle
sur une scène à l'échelle d'un monstre Chambers au
fond du substrat rocheux, il y a quelque chose
là-bas oh mon Dieu, allez, allez, les films sont
si grandioses et épiques et avec un spectacle comme
celui-ci, nous avons le luxe de l'explorer en
10 épisodes, ce qui signifie plus de détails.
drame, c'est vraiment excitant, frappez le
documentaire sur le gaz, il y a deux chronologies dans
cette série, une dans les années 50 et une dans
l'ère moderne et les
personnages d'aujourd'hui ont découvert qu'ils faisaient partie
de cet héritage interconnecté. Notre
père a-t-il vraiment travaillé pour Monarch ?  votre
entreprise familiale c'est la malédiction familiale mon
fils blanc et moi nous jouons la même
personne nous passons de sa période
dans les années 50 à nos jours on nous
a demandé d'être dans le même film
généralement que Père et Fils mais le  L'idée
de jouer la même personne avait un
élément artistique qui nous a attirés. Les choses que
je fais pour Monarch ne seraient pas allées
aussi loin sans toi. Chaque fois que je pense que
nous recherchons papa, il s'avère qu'il y a des
affaires avec Monarch en chemin.
Je suis désolé que tout soit emmêlé
mais oui, toutes ces routes mènent à
un seul endroit, cet équipage que nous suivons de
nos jours est tout aussi nouveau dans le
monde qu'un nouveau spectateur pourrait être le bienvenu
dans Monarch désolé, ce ne sont pas des scientifiques
et  les super-héros, ce sont des gens ordinaires,
tout est nouveau et fou à chaque fois que
vous allez dans des lieux de la série, c'est un
monde complètement différent, nous avons tourné sur un
glacier,
nous avons tourné dans le désert, nous sommes allés à
Tokyo, c'est tout simplement
incroyable, c'est l'expérience la plus enrichissante
d'en faire partie.  de quelque chose d'aussi
cool et d'aussi
grand, j'ai l'impression que le spectacle que nous avions tous prévu de
faire allait être épique et aventureux,
mais tous les sentiments sous-jacents sont
là aussi, cela change
tout, le public qui aime le
vers monstre verra un monde qu'il
reconnaît et  j'ai l'impression que cela a été honoré et que les
nouveaux fans vont regarder ça et dire wow c'est
l'histoire dans laquelle je suis entraîné c'est
un summum du divertissement il y a de
l'action et de l'excitation et tous ces
monstres sont plutôt noueux je dis
ça